et passons
pour un
montant total ignore
donné avant le concert de barbara phrase
user vagabonde on a décidé de geler le
château de monts-sur-guesnes venez avec
nous
[Musique]
je voudrais y bienvenue au château monde
se gagne
le château de montsûrs yens qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une expérience de
découverte scénographique et muséal
c'est un voyage intemporel et
intergénérationnelle l'objectif est pour
faire comprendre et vivre l'histoire à
tout le monde ici on va voyager dans
l'histoire du prêt tout comprendre
pourquoi le poitou elle pourrait tout
sur le plan géographique sur le plan
historique et sur le plan plus largement
culturelle dans sa dimension jusqu'à que
tu as jusqu'à aujourd'hui il ya une
frise du temps à ruban du temps qui nous
permet d'aller de moins 300 milles à
2021 c'est une visite qui va durer à peu
près de 2h30 3h voit qu'à voir quatre
heures suivant les animations et les
jeux que l'on peut faire et donc ces
visites qui se veut numérique d'un côté
et
matériels de l'autre
[Musique]
nous sommes dans la première partie du
château avec cette magnifique cour qui a
été entièrement remonté il faut savoir
que yann elle s'appelle là n'existait
pas là brûlée en 1934 elle s'est
effondrée en 1937 après deux ans de
travaux on a une nouvelle façade à
l'identique de ce qu'elle était avant
d'ailleurs moi se trouve la mairie de
monts-sur-guesnes qui a été restauré
dans les années 80 l'ancien corps de
logis et toute cette partie là dans
lequel on va retrouver notre
scénographie et muséographie d'immersion
totale
[Musique]
ici on est à dernière étape du parcours
près toute la partie numérique immersive
on revient dans le monde réel mais le
monde réel du 12ème 13ème 14ème siècle
puisque derrière moi se trouvent des
engins de tirs d armes de guerre à
taille réelle celle claire moi il y en a
que quatre comme ça dans le monde donc
c'est un grand trébuché à double roue de
carrier ça permettait à l'époque d'
envoyer des pavés 250 kg à une distance
de 200 m donc c'était machine redoutable
l'autre à côté le premier c'est ce qu'on
appelle une bricole entre les deux on a
un petit tri bûcher que l'on peut
utiliser avec les enfants et dans les
tentes qui sont là bas on a également
des jeux en bois et sous le préau aux
mains des démonstrations de tir à l'arc
ou de taille de pierre et après on a
également des fois des démonstrations
d'enluminures
[Musique]